alors moi depuis une quinzaine d'années
que je vis à paris il ya une troupe de
théâtre que j'ai toujours suivi avec
beaucoup d'attention
c'est une troupe dont j'allais voir les
pièces un peu comme les groupes de rock
dont acheter les disques sans les avoir
réellement entendu comme ça simplement
sur leur réputation
comédie policière luxe peine de chlore
d'une chatte anglaise alfredo arias et
sa bande d'argentins ont toujours joué
l'illusion théâtrale la poésie la magie
et j'ai toujours été très attiré par à
re aujourd'hui arias continue puisque il
alla on lui a donné la direction du
théâtre de la commune d'aubervilliers et
la première chose qu'il a fait c'est de
mettre en scène une pièce qui s'appelle
boulevard du mélodrame et qui est
inspiré de la vie de robert macaire qui
est un personnage extrêmement important
un type social très important du 19e
siècle pour jouer robert macaire arias a
appelé un comédien extraordinaire tout à
fait dans la lignée des des victor
boucher les sacha guitry des louis
jouvet ce comédien nous a fait le
plaisir et l'honneur d'être ici
aujourd'hui
il s'appelle jean rochefort
merci les gars
[Musique]
alors jean rochefort est ce que vous
alliez voir les pièces du groupe c c'est
durant ces quinze dernières années
oui j'ai vu lui que j'ai vu
effectivement la chatte anglaise qui m'a
bouleversé
d'autant plus que je les trouve un peu
héritier d'une compagnie que j'ai
pratiqué mois pendant sept ans il y à
déjà fort longtemps qui s'appelait la
compagnie grenier hussenot
et ce sont un peu les héritiers je
trouve spirituel de cette compagnie et
c'est là gentil ce que vous avez dit sur
eux je crois qu'effectivement ils ont un
grand grand grand attention la déchire
au moins est extraordinaire mais c'est
vrai besoin mais ce que j'ai dit sur
vous et aussi avec ce que j'ai dit sur
hier le trouve simplement si vous voulez
carrias à une époque où les gens étaient
un peu déçus par là par la pauvreté
visuel est là la complexité
intellectuelle du théâtre arias est
arrivé avec une grande naïveté une
grande prenant les choses au premier
degré simplement pour le plaisir et je
suis ravi qu'il est qu'il est réussi et
très juste il est arrivé dans une
conjoncture idéale en dehors de son
talent c'était un moment où peut-être
que le théâtre n'était plus de théâtre
il n'y avait plus la joie des émotions
première c'est-à-dire le rire les larmes
le plaisir des yeux et arias et sa
troupe sont arrivés là comme un beau
diamant dans un climat un petit peu
terne et gris voile intégral depuis
plusieurs années je vous propose une
chose savez vous êtes un scoop à la une
alors je vous ai réservé une petite
surprise sur le plateau aujourd'hui j'ai
fait venir le personnage de robert
macaire et nous allons
le voilà donc voilà comment vous serez
habillé sur scène et oui c'est très
impressionnant oui merci philippe jeune
homme qui a ce costume si qui c'est mon
costume c'est le costume que j'aurai
alors robert macaire week-end et il
s'est un peu le père de fantômas et le
père d'arsène lupin
c'est un voyou c'est un voyou qui séduit
les dames et socialement c'est très
étrange parce qu'ils n'hésitent pas à
tuer
c'est un tueur en même temps mais il a
du charme il a le sens de la langue il
parle bien et robert macaire été
interprété à l'époque par un parent un
grand comédien qui s'appelle frédéric
lemaître qui était un peu un titre est
insolent un peu un espèce de coluche est
ce qu'on pourrait dire c'est un espèce
de coluche du 19e siècle willow m tel un
grand acteur et puis en plus donc il a
interprété robert macaire dans une pièce
qui s'appelait l'auberge des intérêts
dont nous sommes largement inspiré mais
est ce qu'on peut dire que le maître a
inventé le mélo à une époque où les gens
étaient encore très habitué à la
tragédie classique c'est à dire qu'il a
été l'événement et qu'il a à travers
neutre quand on parle du mélodrame on
parle beaucoup de fans avec le m
mais le mélodrame existe est très
fortement avant et pendant frédéric
lemaître sur tous les théâtres des
grands boulevards de paris et c'était
une tradition et mon dieu quand on revit
des mélodrames on contrôle le succès et
l'impact que ça avait auprès du public
parce que c'est drôle maintenant mais de
temps en temps c'est tout à fait
tragique et étendre écoutez moi ce que
je voulais simplement vous demandez pour
finir cs quand ça commence que tout le
monde y aille parce que arias et vous ne
méritez tout à fait tout le monde
d'aller voir cette pièce alors de région
de cinq ans quand ça commencera levine
au vent très bien merci beaucoup
dans ce tome ci est maintenant je
oui
voici jean rochefort
[Applaudissements]
heureux de vous avoir sur le plateau de
tout le monde en parle
laurent tu connais les gens je pense non
j'en ressors je me dis quelque chose à
nous d'en faire l'annoncé va à la pêche
écoutez ça va pas mal ouais alors la
moustache au départ vous aviez laissé
pousser la moustache pour jouer alceste
dents lisant propre et puis vous l'avais
gardé parce que vous dites que comme
vous et pas beaucoup de lèvres
supérieures
quand vous avez joué à la moustache
savent dernière un peu hypocrite
oui à lire de très très mais alors ça me
limitais dans les contacts féminins dans
la fiction alors j'avais la forme comme
votre ami johnny hallyday vous allez
urnes parlent que de johnny hallyday
c'est incroyable quand même la france se
donne à johnny hallyday comme ces
données à jacques chirac à un an au
maréchal pétain
à l'époque c'est c'est fou non le
troisième âge trion ouais mais celle
assez c'est assez incroyable
alors vous vous êtes devenu un fan de
johnny hallyday quand vous avez fait le
film de patrice leconte l'homme du train
ça s'est bien passé vous avez très bien
j'ai rencontré là un homme modeste et
timide qui étaient inquiets de tourner
avec nous c'est vrai qu'avant de
commencer le tournage avec johnny vous
aviez des préjugés un petit peu comme
tout le monde sur lui dont on pensait
qu'ils étaient un peu un peu demeuré ou
non pas demeurer ja je ne connaissais
que par les premières pages des journaux
elle je vais sortir bourré d'une boîte
de nuit - des choses ça pour audureau
bras d'une jeune femme
leona est très long non mais c'est moi
de cet excellent anecdotes
bush forum or georges paris
[Applaudissements]
viral
sans le soir des ados lag mais sami
rochefort où ces courageux c'est
grossier quoi jean enfin j'en sors je
connais pas les espoirs - je vous
vouliez une anecdote sur johnny oui
voilà
alors écoutez bien ça ou si nous sommes
dans une salle à manger new rustique
elle 10 km de la belle ville d'annonay
en train de dîner
nous sommes quatre il est 10 heures du
soir banlieue d'hanoi à son préparateur
physique son photographe souffre douleur
et moi même la salle est déserte et tout
à coup une vingtaine de jeunes gens
éclectique avec attaché-case faisant un
séminaire entre dans le brouhaha parfait
et tout à coup à cette table où il ya
tous ces jeunes gens un silence total
et ce silence est totale parce qu l'un
d'eux vient de s'apercevoir que en
banlieue d'annonay à la table occupé il
y à johnny hallyday
ces jeunes gens continuent à dyneon
cependant la fourchette dans la joue pas
ce qu'ils firent les analyser et au
défaire johnny ayant bu deux ou trois
bières de bordeaux parle un peu plus
fort et ces jeunes gens en tant que
jeune idir dit donjon est ici à 10 ans
vendredi
elle m'a fait un potage au potiron plaît
tu veux qu'elle tende et sans un thermos
j'ai vu 20 types broyer
2001 l'oni par celle d'un garçon
sanguins labiles et qu'il cherche pas à
être odieux et sommet de cette
merveilleuse authenticité qui fait son
triomphe
tout à fait jean et vous avez vu aussi
des mecs qui marchaient à quatre pattes
pour ramasser les les micros qui ont la
magie un mégot qui l'avait fait tomber
il ya un type qui l'a ramassée et demi
dans sa bouche
j'étais au bord des larmes mois là vous
le vouliez sais pas je le voulais j'ai
arrêté de fumer il ya longtemps mais ça
fait de la peine un ski très marrant c
qui a longtemps à l'époque où picollier
un peu vous passiez vous dites des
soirées ampleur en vous disant mais que
va faire johnny quand il sera vieux je
prenais de temps en temps des cuites
phénoménal en bretagne et puis on a ça
va être aussi
on leur doit mono juhasz c'était mon
dieu que fera johnny cathy fera quand il
sera prêt et je ne savais pas imaginons
est toujours là il prend pas sa retraite
il a 43 ans de cotisations et c'est vrai
que par rapport au reste de la france
aujourd'hui ça fait ça fait un peu tache
alors vous en parlant de ça vous avez
jamais été très très engagé
politiquement on n'a jamais su très bien
de quel bord alors attiré oui alors
c'est ça je ne suis pas d'un bord précis
je ne suis pas un homme de groulx je
suis profondément individualiste mais
avec une profonde tendresse pour mon
espèce qui me fait beaucoup de peine et
de plus en plus de peine l'homme est un
loup pour l'homme
l'homme est un prédateur c'est oui c'est
le seul pratiquement sur la planète avec
quelques insectes 1 et les chimpanzés
on sait maintenant que trois ou quatre
mâles chimpanzés peuvent parcourir des
centaines et des centaines de kilomètres
arrivé sur un territoire qui n'est pas
le territoire de leurs voisins assassiné
à mal est parti à s'échapper aux
américains sa non non non ils sont
partout à cannes vous avez beaucoup plus
d'américains dont vous étiez jury du
festival non j'en ai vu un qui était
dedans le jour avec moi soderbergh avec
lequel je me suis bien entendu
ouais j'aime être passés par cet amour
et les vidéos genre super jeu parce
qu'ils en vivent
sans lui je les caresse cette moustache
j'aimerais qu'ils gardent un bon
souvenir de vous à cannes c'est votre
chauffeur qui s'en cale ça je le connais
très bien
[Applaudissements]
et puis des institutions locales très
sympa l'idée est simple chauffeur de
jean à cannes et alors il a déclaré dans
nice matin je suis amiens après notre
histoire j'en n'a plus jamais rappelée à
chebba vous l'avais complètement séduite
et abandonnée un bon ben je vais
l'appeler
oui c'est très amoureux de vous et ça
c'est un homme tout à fait des visuels
puis narbonne est bien mais je vais
faire attention c'est d'appeler m'avait
d'ailleurs géant fis venu ici avec
quelqu'un de chez vous moumou mulhouse à
bruges arrive vraiment absolument
épatant chambre année de plein de choses
fondamentales
le palmarès la can le blizzard dont vous
l'avez fait exprès ou quoi
écoutez la sphère est délicat l'affairé
délicate
on n'avait pas grand choix enfin il et
karin viard comme est très sympa quand
même très très très sain extrêmement
brillant et très sympa c'est qu'elle est
venu ici car ça ne m'étonne je lui ai
demandé un jour je lui ai dit karine
qu'est ce que vous préférez dans le sexe
elle m'a répondu l'habite au mcee non
mais attends juste et vous passez en
même temps quand on a dit ici c'est pas
le parisien
c'était c'était avant ou après ces six
là c'était bien avant aujourd'hui non
pas dans le festival de cannes nous
avons quand même subi une selle lation
de vie minutes et demie c'est quand même
lyon et demi et ça m'a fait raser les
murs pendant des semaines parce que
l'homme avait un sexy mans j'ai appris
récemment que c'était une prothèse
aujourd'hui retrouvé le moral et dites
moi j'emmène ryan vous l'avez brancher
un peu
meg ryan jeu les branches et chéri lui a
passé ah oui oui je mets ça s'est passé
divinement bien avec miss univers la
crise un dieu oui qu'est ce qu'elle est
belle elle est magnifique et elle m'a
laissé petit papy la ville des petits
bijoux incrustés incrusté dans le carton
des petits de pacotille un doux quoi
exotique mais avec love juste que j'aime
ça en fait ce que je préfère chez vous
j'en sais votre timidité
c'est dire que dans dans les films de
dont on parle toujours l'éléphant ça
trompe énormément nous irons tous au
paradis
cette espèce de timidité que vous avez
comme ça je trouve ça touchant
je trouve ça très craquant gymnase
émerveille encore et qu'une jeune femme
comme ça mais ophélie winter a voulu
m'embrasser de reculer alors belle était
trop bas qui est le prétexte il a donné
ses patrons frame mois mais en fait ça
bouleverse
vous avez toujours été comme ça me
débecte les filles à l'âge de 22 ans
fumer la pipe dans votre coin
et puis vous vous appelez le philosophe
quoi vous aviez du mal à j'étais très
timide je n'entrais pas dans le jeu j'en
ai beaucoup souffert
et puis c'est venu petit à petit
l'acquisition de la moustache aussi je
pense 25 ou sattouf les libérer pas et
mais elle ne s'est pas fait c'est vrai
que vous vous étiez plutôt partisan de
deux choses comme ça on faisait des
franchises un petit baiser le soir quand
les parents étaient partis en fin
c'était vous devez être effondré quand
vous voyez les films pornos aujourd'hui
à la télé ou même même les émissions de
télévision n'est en tout cas ne pensais
pas que je sois
un homme austère embêtant je vais je
passe pour un amant exceptionnel et je
laissais veille
il est vrai que que l'hypocrisie dans la
sexualité est resté pour moi stimuli met
en place et il est vrai que le sexe
exposés est ce qu'un profondément ma
libido
bah oui parce qu'il fut de transgression
a lâché 2 agrégation je suis
baudelairien c'est connaître la
sexualité dans les toilettes d'une école
communale puis là que tout vient alors
c'est tout un monde que je découvre
maintenant et c'est vrai que cet
affichage permanent et un cas est
actuellement
alors j'ai devenu culte maintenant parce
que c'est vrai que bonvoisin fait film
blanche avec vous chabal et robin des
bois ça y est quoi jeolla vous êtes dans
une autre dimension c'est encore ce
encore ailleurs la non oui c'est vrai je
suis en train de vivre un hommage
posthume de mon vivant
ce qui est mieux donc on en profite
c'est arrivé parce que il ya eu déjà
deux césar et que la fête commence il le
crabe tambour et en 99 un césar
d'honneur ça sent le sapin mais ça
voulait dire allez hop là on a cru qu'il
a cru qu'il allait mourir
et puis voilà et puis finalement non
vous êtes toujours là malgré les
ardennaises édition mais qu il m'a porté
la poisse
ils sont bien failli avoir raison
on y arrive on y rit parce qu'il ya un
film qui n'aura jamais de césar
un film qui ne sortira jamais mesdames
messieurs
l'homme qui tua don quichotte terry
gilliam avec johnny depp vanessa paradis
et notre ami jean rochefort
ça a très mal commencé d'abord y est
j'ai les boules litres déjà déjà le tipi
ensuite il y avait dès le début du
tournage
il y avait des avions de vouziers
tournier juste en dessous des avions de
chasse qui faisait un bruit infernal
toute la journée il ya eu un orage qui
emporte en fait le temps voilà tu tout
le décor
c'était déjà terrible et alors huit
jours après le début du tournage vous
j'en reçois vous êtes victime d'une
hernie inguinale
oui entre autres c'était plus compliqué
que s'arrachent pas de réponse sur les
petits malheurs mince à 6 il ya eu un
vrai désastre physiologique tout à
craquer donc le dos la hernie inguinale
dernière dans le périnée est alors 1ère
place et affreusement périnée ça fait
mal quand terminé et ça fait très mal et
obligé d'arrêter le tournage et ce qui
est extraordinaire c'est que vous dans
votre carrière j'ai fait quoi 150 films
- jamais arrêté un jour même mais je
n'ai jamais manqué un jour jamais 20 ans
de théâtre tous les soirs et 130 et
quelques films
donc j'étais vraiment broyés par là
cette chose à d'autant que c'était
parlons un peu sérieusement c'était un
peu un rêve pour moi à terry gilliam
était un rêve johnny depp était un fan
parce que j'adorais ses films avec
jarmusch oignons et là vous dites
johnny depp qui a qui est un petit peu
de sang indien il a ce respect des
personnages et là ses limites
il est venu vers vous avec beaucoup de
beaucoup d'attentions beaucoup de
chaleur venue salomé patent rhin ça a
été comme une espèce de fils artistiques
comme ça
ils ont été épatants tous les deux avec
vanessa comme deux enfants
s'apercevant n'ya pas va mourir j'étais
vraiment espérer que vous aviez vous
vous remettre tout le monde a tout fait
mais en fait pas du tout c'est à dire
que d'abord on a cru un moment où le
cancer faut dire la vérité et voilà quoi
ce qui n'était pas le cas malgré le
césar d'honneur et vous êtes resté sept
mois au lit et là votre françoise a été
formidable de petites mondial mais moi
je suis rentré chez moi donc la douleur
j'ai demandé à ma femme c'est bizarre
comme le psychisme et physiologique mais
enfin c'est pareil j'ai appris ça
maintenant j'ai voulu faire des photos
que ma femme me prennent en photo avec
une fourchette
une râpe à à gruyères et une espèce de
timbale en métal pour qu'elles prennent
des photos de moi totalement dérisoire
en tee shot et on a fait cette série de
photos que je n'ai toujours pas regardé
et je suis monté dans ma chambre et je
suis resté couché sept mois mais j'ai
voulu avant de me coucher faire ces
photos et me piétiner la dernière build
comme une dernière pitreries quoi oui
alors bon au départ tout mon espère vous
remettre 15 jours voilà ils réalisent
que le film se fera jamais vous avez
beaucoup de mal à en parler
jusqu'au jour où à l'ombre vous assister
à la projection du making of du film
parce qu'elle est une équipe qui
tournait qui a filmé ces espèces de
désastre gigantesque que ça a été
l'équipe c qui fut l'automne et louis
pépé donc qui ont fait celui graf et le
making off s'appelle lost in la mancha
perdu dans la mancha donc évidemment
c'est bien fait et je trouve moi que le
fait finalement que le film jambes a
fait et qui ce making of sur le fait que
le film était un échec
c'est beaucoup plus cliché obtient que
cc c'est pire en des liens assez d'ego
ou même les gens délicieusement absurde
oui making of mais ya pas de off voilà
c'est ça
voilà seul film qui n'existe pas et
qu'on voit à travers un à travers un
making-of alors woody allen a déclaré au
sujet de ce making of
c'est le pire cauchemar qu'un
réalisateur puisse vivre mais c'est
tellement réjouissant
[Rires]
voilà ça
lost in la mancha et le making of du
film inachevé de terry gilliam avec tes
liliane dont johnny depp jean rochefort
et vanessa paradis
je viens l'air et mis en ligne en ne la
regardais pas voulu te regarde et puis
après je me suis retourné
encore une toute petite chose minuscule
je veux pas qu'on croie que je suis
incapable de faire marcher un cheval au
pape mais il consacrer la moitié de ma
vie à sa wii et dans les dents les
catastrophes supplémentaires ce cheval
est mort je lance ma nourriture tout
simplement parce que on avait décidé
pour qu'il ait l'air de rossinante de ne
pas lui donner à bouffer pendant trois
mois un bonjour la spa 1 et bonjour le
spleen de rochefort comme ça ça m'a
foutu un coup dur mais j'ai bien rigolé
vous ça vous n'avez pas gueuler en un
mot sur emule ma tête mais je n'ai plus
la force doit alors complètement
non non je ne peux plus monter c'est
terrible parce que vous avez un rapport
au cheval qui est très intéressant c'est
à dire que vous avez été mais les
tréteaux au monde du cheval puisque
votre grand père avait une compagnie de
fiacre à dinan et vous n'êtes pas bon en
fait vous montiez pas malgré ça et à
l'âge de 30 ans n'est pas non plus tout
jeune vous faites cartouches
vous montez à ce moment là sur un cheval
et vous n'entendrez jamais c'est à dire
que j'arrête la compétition à 48 ans
avaient alors pourquoi vouliez pas monté
sur un cheval je crois que c'est parce
que vous aviez peur d'avilir lallaoui
noble conquête de l'homme
vous pensez que j'ai assez le respect
des êtres pas des choses mais des êtres
et je pensais qu'on n'avait pas le droit
de monter sur le dos de l'animal ou d'un
homme
ouais ça me gênait beaucoup je voulais
courir à côté ça énervait mon père mais
alors c'est pour ça que j'ai réussi très
tard et à la 3d
ce qui est incroyable c'est quand vous
montez sur un cheval à l'âge de 30 ans
il ya quelque chose qu'il se réveille en
vous au niveau génétique quoi parce que
je joue la famille était là dedans
pourquoi vous devenu complètement fou de
cheval mais ça devient pour vous une
passion pratiquement à 50 50 avec le
cinéma est un métier alors une histoire
extraordinaire c'est un jour jean et à
saint lô dans une foire
et puis un type qui s'approche la
vieille éleveurs normands 1,8 cheveux
comme ça grince sous la casquette en
tweed un groupe itg tout rouge
c'était à saint lô c'était la vente des
étalons de l'année voit la broche de moi
même division s'est vu avec la télé fait
pour que tu faisais du cinéma
ma vie
alors j'en ressors comme vous êtes en
très bonne santé tout le monde peut le
constater c'est le moment de vous faire
l'interview jugement dernier
[Musique]
c'est l'heure du jugement dernier
jean hétu près pas encore mais bon genre
oui as tu pu en moi
à une époque oui pourquoi as-tu cessé de
croire en moi gens parce que j'ai cessé
parce que j'y ai cru en vous par
trouille de la mort mais je sais que
vous n'arrange rien là haut tu fais
chier jean jean as tu déjà pêché par
penser par action par omission ou à la
mouche pêcher à la mouche jamais par
omission jamais et par ponk c'est tout
le temps jean tuffou dessus en laye un
tournage en prétextant un quelconque mal
au dos non j'ai foutu en l'air un
tournage en prétextant une douleur dans
le périnée qui est située entre l'anus
et les testicules
jean hugues hausman
jean as-tu déjà participé à des
émissions de télévision sous l'emprise
de substances illicites
non mais ce soir j'aurais dû
[Applaudissements]
non tu déjà regardé tf1 le samedi soir
en deuxième partie de soirée
non non jamais pourvu que ça dure as tu
déjà commis l'acte de chair sans volonté
reproductrices oui de nombreuses fois
les gens gardent un souvenir est pas
tant la plaie jean desailly et n'est pas
intelligent desailly très bien ce genre
as-tu déjà trompé ta maîtresse
non je ne suis pas un trompeur j'ai eu
des grandes passions
mais je ne trompais pas je partais est
ce que tu te repent de tous tes péchés
gens non c'était le plus agréable
chan
[Musique]